Consider this unfortunately familiar scenario.
Several months ago, a highly infectious, sometimes deadly respiratory virus...
...infected humans for the first time.
It then proliferated faster than public health measures could contain it.
Now, the World Health Organization has declared a pandemic,...
...meaning that it's spreading worldwide.
The death toll is starting to rise, and everyone is asking the same question:...
When will the pandemic end?
The WHO will likely declare the pandemic over...
...once the infection is mostly contained...
...and rates of transmission drop significantly throughout the world,...
...but exactly when that happens depends on what global governments choose to do next.
They have three main options:...
...Race through it, delay and vaccinate, or coordinate and crush.
One is widely considered best, and it may not be the one you think.
In the first, governments and communities do nothing to halt the spread...
...and instead allow people to be exposed as quickly as possible.
Without time to study the virus,...
...doctors know little about how to save their patients,...
...and hospitals reach peak capacity almost immediately.
Somewhere in the range of millions to hundreds of millions of people die,...
...either from the virus or the collapse of health care systems.
Soon, the majority of people have been infected...
...and either perished or survived by building up their immune responses.
Around this point, herd immunity kicks in, where the virus can no longer find new hosts.
So, the pandemic fizzles out a short time after it began.